How's it going everyone and welcome to
the fifth video in my weekly profile
series. In this video, we'll be talking
about the Thursday counter weekly
profile and a shout out to AM Trades as
this is who taught me this profile.
Let's get into the PDF. So a Thursday
counter is when Thursday counters the
weekly range. So what do we have Monday,
Tuesday and Wednesday or what are the
requirements? Monday, Tuesday and
Wednesday expand away without creating a
significant low. So here you can see
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, they all
expand away from the weekly open and we
don't have a significant low here.
Thursday then forms a candle to closure
which counters the range and then I can
look back towards the weekly open or the
current week low as we have a large wick
which means it is a reversal candle. And
here in the bullish scenario, Monday,
Tuesday and Wednesday expand lower,
Thursday counters that move and then
Friday we look back towards that weekly
open, the current high of the week or
any failure swings that are resting.
So how does this actually form? Monday,
Tuesday, Wednesday trade away, Thursday
counters that move. If we are seeking
the continuation, when are we going to
want to look inside this candle for an
hourly change in the state of delivery?
With that hourly change in the state of
delivery, we have confirmed this wick on
the daily time frame and then we can
seek trading candle three or this
continuation on Friday for the move
lower. And the same with the bullish
scenario, Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday
expand lower, Thursday counters that
range. We check inside Thursday's range.
Do we have an hourly change in the state
of delivery? If we do, we can seek that
continuation on Friday.
Now Thursday counter is actually one of
those scenarios where I will actually
look to trade the reversal day. And as
long as this has a small wick, usually
paired with SMT off of a previous day
high or a previous day low, I will look
to trade the reversal day in this
scenario as it can set up for a really
great one-sided move. But now that you
understand what a Thursday counter
weekly profile looks like, let's go into
TradingView and go over a few examples
of this.
So here we are in our first example and
Friday, what do we notice? We have a
candle to closure.
This is paired with an SMT. Now as I
talked about in the previous video as
well as on Twitter, when can I look to
trade Monday? When Friday forms a
reversal or a candle to closure. So with
this candle three, I could look to trade
Monday higher.
Monday we do get this move higher. Do we
reverse off this high? No, we do not
form a reversal candle yet. And then
Tuesday, we are expanding higher. So
where are we likely to reach for? This
high up here. What happens on Wednesday?
We get a continuation into that high. So
now we've had what? Monday, Tuesday and
Wednesday all expand higher or in one
direction and what have we not made? We
haven't made a significant low inside
this weekly range, right? We do have a
low but that was formed on Friday. So
now that we have formed an expansion
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, we have hit
a relevant level. This is where we could
get a new phase of price, right? We
could look to see is Thursday going to
counter this range? Now since we've a
closed on the high, generally we want to
see what? Candle to closure off of this
high or that means a sweep of previous
day high or some sort of SMT. With this
we're going to go down to the hourly
time frame.
Now down here on the hourly time frame,
we went ahead and turned on my indicator
and let's see what happens here.
So you can see
we have our previous day high. That will
be our point of interest. We want to see
this taken out or an SMT on that. Here
you can see we take out the previous day
high with an SMT. We have a change in
the state of delivery confirming this
wick. So we could look for a
continuation inside this reversal day or
we can wait for Friday for the
continuation day.
So what do we get? We get a nice
expansion lower. So adding the weekly
candle on there, what does this weekly
profile tell us? We have not made an
established low on Monday. You can see
we have failure swings. We expand away
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday. Thursday is
now countering that range. We have a
change in the state of delivery paired
with an SMT. We could be looking for
Friday to do what? Have a continuation
day lower. Lower to where? Well ideally
the weekly open, the current week low or
the failure swings resting below. So
let's see what happens on this
continuation day.
So here we go into the next day.
And you can see we get a continuation.
We have a previous day's low that we
hit. Ideally we want to see this
continue lower and there we are into our
weekly open. Now on this new week, we
could be looking for a continuation into
these failure swings lows but let's
rewind this one more time just to review
the weekly profile.
What do we have? We have a reversal
candle on the weekly. Monday, Tuesday
and Wednesday all expand higher and then
what do we have? Thursday counters that
range which provides the opportunity
with a small wick or you can wait for
the continuation day on Friday looking
to target that weekly open and the
current week's low.
Let's get into another example.
So here we are in our next example and
what do we notice? We have Monday right
here.
Tuesday, Wednesday, we all expand away
from the weekly open. Monday do we form
a relevant low? Not really. We're quite
close to this low enough to consider a
failure swing. We also have a failure
swing here. So what could we be looking
for? We could be looking for Thursday to
counter the range and see if we get a
continuation lower back towards the
weekly open on Friday. Now here,
normally we look to target the weekly
open or the intraweek low. Does it
really make sense here? Probably not.
Not expecting Nasdaq to hit this amount
of range in one day with our average
daily range being a lot less than that.
So let's see what happens here. Ideally,
what are we looking for? We want to see
if this wick respects, right? So what do
I mean by that? Do we form the wick of
the daily candle in this lower half in
this T-spot here? So do we open? Do we
form a high and then form a continuation
we can look to trade the lower. So let's
see what happens.
What do we do?
We just slowly grind up and there we go.
We start to get a move lower.
Let's see if we can form a continuation
intraday here. We do have a nice fair
value gap.
Let's see what happens.
Okay, we're reaching this fair value gap
and what do we do? We expand through
this fair value gap. So it is not
respecting this area to continue lower.
It's more so consolidating. So just
because a weekly profile is forming does
not mean that it is going to work,
right? It is not 100%. Things do fail.
So let's see what happens here.
We respect this inversion and we end up
trading through the high. So we don't
actually get that Friday move lower. And
I'm just showing this example that not
all weekly profiles when they occur, it
doesn't have to happen. It doesn't mean
you did something wrong. It's just
nothing works 100% of the time. Let's
get into another example. So here we are
in our next example and we have Friday
from the previous week forming a
reversal and expansion candle. So we
could be looking for a continuation of
this move early into this next week. So
Monday we get a move higher.
Tuesday we also get a move higher. Now a
lot of people struggle choosing a point
of interest. What do we notice here? We
have a fair value gap. You can just look
for the daily closures in that area. Is
it respected? No. So I don't really have
to worry about it. Here we have another
fair value gap with failure swings. So
ideally we go reach up into there if
we're going to get a Thursday counter.
Wednesday we reach up there. We have
expanded away.
This is in candle two, three, four,
five, six. So ideally Thursday counter
makes sense. I want to be looking for a
new phase of price but ideally we run
out these highs here so we can get a new
phase of price. So I could look to trade
the reversal day or I could see what
happens, right? What do we do? We reach
up into here and we have a candle to
closure. Now you might be saying hey, we
have a candle to closure on both sides.
Why are you bearish? Well, that's what
makes sense in terms of the weekly
profile, right? This is where it's
actually useful. Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday expands away. Thursday forms a
reversal. I would rather trade this back
into the range than try to trade it back
higher on a Monday low of week. So this
is where we're going to drop down to the
hourly chart. So down here on the hourly
chart, what do we have? We have that
Thursday reversal. So we could be
looking for a Friday continuation. And
once again, yes we have a candle two on
bullish and bearish sides but only the
bearish side has an hourly change in the
state of delivery. So I would not trust
this low to hold. I'd be looking for
this to move lower on Friday today. So
letting this play out, do we end up
getting a move lower?
We do get a move lower. Do we reach
towards that weekly open? Yes. Do we hit
it?
No, we don't. Now here is an example.
It's going to be a quick one but I want
to talk about the logic of this. This
logic can be applied even if things are
not perfect. Now ideally we have Monday,
Tuesday and Wednesday all expand and
then Thursday counter, Friday
continuation. Here you can see Monday
does not expand, right? Monday just
forms a reversal. Then we get a Tuesday
and Wednesday continuation
and then we do get that Thursday
counter, right? And then Friday
continuation. The whole goal of showing
this is yes, Monday did not expand then
Tuesday then Wednesday, right? Monday is
a reversal. We only get a Tuesday and
Wednesday expansion. That doesn't mean
that Thursday cannot counter the range.
Here you can see it does get an
expansion and a counter at the same time
but not everything's going to be perfect
within the weekly profile but you can
still use the logic of it. So here we
are in our last example, and once again,
this is not a perfect example. Take a
look at Thursday. What do we do? Well,
we don't actually take out our Wednesday
high.
So, I would still consider this a
Thursday counter as Thursday is
countering the range. Wednesday isn't
really forming that reversal there.
But, what do we notice? Even if you
can't catch this reversal day, you can
take a look at the profile. Monday,
Tuesday, Wednesday expand higher.
Thursday counters the range. That gives
you bias for what? For Friday. Friday to
trade in towards that weekly open as
well as the current week's low, which it
does. Now, if you use intermarket
analysis and take a look at, you know,
ES or NQ here, you can see that reversal
was formed on Wednesday. So, it's
actually a Thursday continuation of a
midweek reversal. And if you apply that,
you could also be looking for a reversal
on this day as the other assets reversed
on Wednesday. But, with that, I hope you
enjoyed this video. If you have any
questions, please leave them in the
comment section below, and I'll try to
get to them. But, other than that, if
you enjoyed, please like it. Please
subscribe, and I'll see you guys next
week. Have a good one.